The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to
use this final time--
hour we have together to
summarize a few of what I take
to be the central themes
of course, the organizing
ideas that, at least
have seemed to me,
to structure our
argument and our progress
through these, through this
almost 100 years of movies.
The first idea, one that
we've come back to, I think,
again and again,
has to do with what
we might call film in its
anthropological or sociological
aspect.
Film as a cultural form, as
an expression of a culture,
as something that
grows out of a culture,
that expresses the values
and prejudices and well
weirdness of a culture.
From this angle, questions
of aesthetic value,
questions of
artistic excellence,
are irrelevant in some sense.
From this angle, we're
thinking about film
simply as a central expression,
as a central habit our culture.
Itself and we might recognize
that in the 20th century, where
film was the dominant
narrative form,
the film performed functions
in the 20th century
that earlier forms of
storytelling, of narrative end
drama, had played
in earlier cultures.
And one of my deep
desires in the course,
one of my implicit ambitions
all the way through,
was to encourage you to think
about movies in this way,
as an expression of the
values and assumptions
on the 20th century cultures,
which might be in earlier times
have been expressed
in other media.
And it was important
for me to have
you recognize that our 20th
and 21st century, although it's
somewhat different
in the 21st century,
because films are--
film is undergoing
such a profound transformation
in the digital age.
Nonetheless, in the
20th and 21st century,
audio, visual narrative
is a dominant experience
for virtually
everyone in the world.
In earlier societies, we
didn't have this option,
but it didn't mean that the
functions played by the movies
weren't played by earlier forms.
So that's been one of
the deep assumptions, one
of the recurring
principles to which I've
recurred through the course.
And another aspect of this idea,
something I've come back to,
I think several times,
has been the relationship
between storytelling
and culture.
And drawing especially on
certain anthropological and
historical sources, I've
tried to suggest to you
that one way of
understanding culture
itself, is to understand
culture through its stories,
is to understand that the
stories a culture tells
reveal the culture
in basic ways.
Not necessarily reveal
the culture at its best,
although sometimes
they may do so,
but they reveal the culture
in powerful and central ways.
And some of our
work in this course,
as I hope you recognize, has
been attempt in some ways
to recover what might
be called the cultural,
or the anthropological, or
the sociological assumptions
and beliefs that are
embedded in our movies.
One of the most
important aspects
of this principle of
storytelling as intimately
connected to the
progress of culture
has to do with an
idea I suggested early
in the term, the idea that
culture itself-- and this
is what I think, one of the
great insights of 20th century
cultural history,
cultural analysis--
is the recognition the
culture itself is a completely
unfinished thing, that it's
never a single fixed item.
That culture itself is,
society itself is always
in the process of
evolving and changing.
That it's idea of itself
is always in flux.
This is an immensely
productive way
of understanding what society
is, because what it allows
us to do is recognize that the
various expressive and other--
especially the expressive
forms of a culture,
play a central role
in what we might call
this ongoing attempt
of a society to define
and renew itself according to
various values and assumptions,
and historical inheritances.
But also that the culture
uses these stories
as a way to react to
disturbances and challenges
to the social fabric.
And remember, borrowing on
the great English cultural
historian Raymond Williams, I
suggested in an earlier course,
in earlier class,
that one of the ways
to think about this
process is to imagine
culture itself as
consisting of sort
of three strands or voices.
An emerging voice,
which represents
new ideas, the future, right?
Emergent voices.
Dominant or central
voices, where
the central values of a society
are embedded and articulated.
And on the other
side, what might
be quote traditional
or vestigial voices.
The voices or energies that
are losing force, losing power,
as society changes,
that belong to a past,
but are still part of the mix.
And once we understand
that culture
is this constant sort of our
ongoing, mixed conversation
amongst traditional,
dominant, and emerging voices,
we begin to understand much
more about the complexity of how
a culture proceeds.
And of course, what
this also does,
once we make the link between
the stories a culture tells
and the cultures'
idea of itself,
we can recognize that
this same process can
work for understanding stories.
It's immensely
liberating, immensely
illuminating, to recognize
that of course films,
like other forms of
narrative, are going
to do contain elements that are
not completely coherent, not
completely in agreement.
That they actually may
sustain contradictions.
That films, like other
forms of narrative,
may very well
articulate both emergent
and traditional voices,
and those two voices
may be in conflict, or at
least not in perfect coherence
in a particular text.
So, one of the advantages
of this perspective
is to allow us to
recognize something
of the complexity, even the
dynamic and potentially partly
contradictory elements that we
may find in particular films.
So the idea that culture
is always unfinished, never
a fixed or finished thing,
and that the stories a culture
tells are a part of this ongoing
conversation, this dynamic,
always unfinished conversation
about the value he was
and assumptions the
society lives by.
I suggested a number
of times that one way
to think about the central
or the dominant narrative
forms in particular cultures,
film in the 20th century,
the novel in the 18th and 19th
century in certain European
and in American society, the
public theater of Shakespeare's
day, the oral
formulaic narrative
in the ancient world of Homer.
And what I've suggested is that
these narrative forms might
be labeled, can usefully be
labeled as consensus forms,
because they understand
themselves to occupy
a central space in the society.
That they recognize,
not necessarily
that they're expressing
a true consensus,
no society has a
perfect consensus,
but that what they
recognize is that they're
expressing what is the
imagined, or the accepted,
or the presumed
consensus of the culture.
That consensus of values may
not be bought into by everyone,
certainly won't be.
Nonetheless, even the people
who don't accept the consensus
values recognize what the
dominant values of the culture
are, and recognize those
sites, like the movies
in the 20th century, that
are the carriers of what
we might call that official
or consensus meaning.
And one of things
I tried to suggest
to you in the course
of our discussions
is the way in which, in
the 20th century form
of film, the central
role that genre forms
play in this process.
And can you see why
that would be true?
One reason is that there's
an implicit principle
of repetition within
variation in genre forms,
because they're so familiar.
Different as a late Western
and an early Western might be,
they're still Westerns and
they share a great deal.
They share certain
fundamental qualities
that every viewer recognizes.
The more literate the
viewer or the reader
is in the conventions
of a particular genre,
the richer the
uses of that genre
become, especially as the genre
elaborates itself over time.
And one of the things I've
tried to show you by talking,
especially about the
Western in American society,
was to suggest that
we can actually
understand some of
these genre forms
as in some sense mirroring
the debate a society
may very well be having
about its own nature.
And that the way the
Western changes over time
in the history of film is a kind
of distillation this process,
whereby the stories of a
culture help the story,
help the culture to
accommodate itself to changes,
help the help of
culture figure out how
its past and its
present can be brought
into some kind of relation,
help but help the society
get used to change and dynamic
challenges to its coherence.
One implication of
the kind of argument
I've been making about
consensus narrative,
as I've suggested
a number of times,
is that a consensus
narrative always--
what I'm calling
consensus narrative.
We might use a simpler
and less aggressive term,
we might say various
forms of popular culture
share the same qualities
with the particular form
of popular culture I'm
calling consensus narrative.
And remember, one of
the exciting things
about this concept is that
it shifts from culture
to culture, or from era to era.
The consensus narrative
system of one society
won't be the same as
that of another society,
but the systems
will share certain--
in one case it might be
the novel, in another case
it might be the film,
but both system will--
both of these forms,
when there are
consensus system,
consensus forms,
will share certain qualities.
And I've suggested that the
central qualities they share
are that they are always in some
deep way conservative, right?
They're both morally
conservative,
or conservative in
terms of content,
because they're trying to
reach the whole of the society
and they have to be
careful about that,
they can't be as
advanced or as radical
as the most radical, or avant
garde parts of the culture,
because certain
elements of the culture
would be alienated
by it, and it's
the cultural work of
consensus narrative
to address the
center of society.
So they're conservative in
content and the moral values.
And there are also
conservative artistically.
That is to say,
they don't do a lot
of sort of daring and shocking,
technical or structural
experiments.
Again, because they
want to be, because they
aim to be understood by a large
proportion of the population.
They aim to be
readable by everyone.
And that brings us to
do a second item that's
an aspect of, always a
fundamental aspect of consensus
narrative, they're accessible.
That they are written
or created in a language
according to archetypes, or
stereotypes, or shared tropes
and conventions
that are accessible,
readable to the
whole of the society.
And a final feature that
these texts always have
is that they are collaborative.
And I've suggested
earlier in the course
that one way to think about how
collaborative the movies are
is to recognize in every movie
is itself a collaboration.
That you can't make
a movie-- one person
can never make a movie.
That a movie is always
a collaborative form.
But, I mean this
idea of collaboration
in a deeper way as well.
Not only is the text,
are the text of movies
literally collaboratively
created by many, many creators,
but they're collaborative it
another way, in a deep way.
Of course the most
obvious one is the way
in which you all genre forms
collaborate with themselves,
the way they're in a
kind of conversation
with all prior
instances of the genre.
And what that means is the
genre forms are collaborating
with their history, their
collaborating with their--
and they're also
implicitly collaborating
with the audience's
literate knowledge of what
these genre forms are
like, how they behave, what
the expectations in them are.
And their collaborative in yet
another way, and this aspect
of their collaborative
characters
is one that I haven't
emphasized too much,
and I want to do it today in our
final, in our farewell lecture.
They're collaborative
also because these text,
in some deep way,
are collaborating
with what we might call the
collective wisdom or values
of the culture.
And this is implicit
in what I've
been saying about the way
these story forms draw
on the histories, and stories,
and conventions that are most
widely shared in a culture.
But I want to
clarify what I mean
by-- so there's that kind of
collaboration, in which they're
constantly borrowing forms,
and arguments, and principles,
and symbols from the vast
body of shared knowledge
that a culture might have.
But what this might
actually lead to-- one thing
this leads to is the recognition
that these cultural forms
are not always
noble or wonderful,
that they carry prejudices,
that they carry racism,
that they carry misogyny,
that they're going to embody,
that the study of these
texts is not necessarily,
never should be a totally
celebratory experience, even
though many of these texts are
what valuable, and lasting,
and speak to us in deep and
powerful and useful ways.
It's also true that these text
carried the lies and prejudices
of the cultures from
which they come,
as I've said a number
of times in the course.
Perhaps too many times.
But I mentioned again
in this last lecture,
because I want to also mention
that there's a way in which,
not just the evils and the
limitations of a society that
get expressed in the
collaborative consensus
forms that emerge
from them, but also
sometimes the wisdom
of society does too.
In other words, what
I want to suggest
to you is that the
collaboration has
to do not only with inherited
values, and inherited beliefs,
and inherited story
forms, they also
have also have to do with the
kind of inheritance of wisdom.
And I have a
particularly exciting way
of distilling this for you.
There's a passage, one
of my favorite passages,
from Shakespeare, from his from
his great late play Cymbeline.
From Act four, scene two, in
which a group of characters
gather around a body.
They think the body actually
comes alive later in the play,
because there's a lot of
wonderful magic in the play,
it's a play about
redemption and rebirth.
But at this moment in the play,
they think this person is dead,
and they single dirge.
It's one of the most-- a dirge,
a song, a funeral song, a song
or a poem to be sung or
recited at a graveside.
And there's, maybe the
greatest of all such dirges
is in English, is in Cymbeline.
And this is the first stanza
and the greatest stanza,
fear no more--
right there, people
are standing over corpse.
Fear no more the
heat of the sun;
Nor the furious winter's
rages, Thou thy worldly task
hath done, Home art gone
and taken thy wages.
Very interesting to image, to
embrace a metaphor of working,
a working class metaphor.
You're dying, and
the metaphor is,
you've taken your last wages,
you finished your work.
Home art gone and
taken they wages.
And here comes the couplet
that I think is most powerful.
Golden lads and girls all
must, as chimney sweepers,
come to dust.
Let me say it again so
you get the whole stanza,
it's quite beautiful, I think.
Fear no more the
heat of the sun;
Nor the furious winters'
rages, Thou thy worldly task
hath done, Home art gone
and taken thy wages.
Golden lads and girls all
must, As chimney sweepers
come to dust.
Now think about those
last lines for a minute.
They're very powerful, even
if you don't exactly get them.
Golden lads and girls, the
implication is high born,
wealthy, golden in their
youth, and in their energy
and in their vitality.
No matter how golden,
whether in wealth,
or a vitality, even
golden lads and girls
end up in the grave
like all of us.
And there's, the
implication of course,
is there's a kind of
constellation in the fact that
it's-- deaths is
our shared fate.
It's a consoling, an
attempt to console us.
Although the older I
get, the less consolation
I find myself taking
from this insight.
Nonetheless, it is a great
poem, and this stanza
is a particularly
remarkable poem
because of one element in
it, the phrase, golden lads.
For those of you know-- very
few Americans know this,
but some Brits know this.
In Shakespeare's
native Warwick shire,
the phrase golden lad referred
to something very specific.
It referred to the condition
of the common ordinary flower
that we call the dandelion.
And it's a flower that has
a gold cup when it's young,
and then when it goes
to seed, and you've all
seen them, because they're
native to North America as well
as England.
The top of the cap
turns into a kind
of rounded series of filaments,
a beautiful round cap and when
you-- a lot that children
pick them and blow them,
and the seeds blow all over.
One of the reasons that these
common weedy flowers are
so common, is that they're so
brilliantly designed by nature
to propagate, because
the wind blows
their seeds all over the place.
Do you all have
an image of this?
So when you're young, the
flowers have these golden caps,
and then when they go to
seed, they become these,
they have these rounded
filaments on the top.
And these rounded filaments,
in Shakespeare's day,
were called golden lads when
they-- were actually called,
these flowers were called golden
lads when they were in bloom,
and they were called
chimney sweeps
when they went to seed,
because they looked exactly
like a chimney sweepers broom.
Chimney sweepers we take
these rounded brooms
and put them up in
chimneys to clean them.
So when Shakespeare
writes in the end there,
he says, golden lads and girls
all must, as chimney sweepers,
come to dust.
He's describing literally the
phases of life in a flower.
Why is that wonderful?
Can you see why
that's wonderful?
Why that's what art is?
Because of course,
what's happened
is that, what
Shakespeare did was
create a brilliant metaphor
out of something that's
profoundly concrete.
So the phrase golden
lad and chimney sweeper
actually refers to the
life cycle of a flower.
Well think of how
much more consoling,
how profoundly brilliant
the lines become,
when actually Shakespeare's
metaphor is literally
linked to the
passages of nature,
to the progress of nature.
So what I'm calling
your attention to
is a brilliant piece of
poetry, a piece of poetry that
has a kind of richness
and complexity
that almost couldn't be better.
And even when we don't
know that about the flower,
we get the meaning of
the lines, but think
how the lines come
alive once we recognize
that the progress of human
life in those couplets
is being explicitly
associated with the life
cycle of a natural
object of a flower.
Now this is a great act of
poetic geniuses, isn't it?
But where does the genius lie?
Where does it come--
Shakespeare is collaborating
with the wisdom of his culture.
It takes Shakespeare
to figure it out,
I mean I'm not saying that
it is an act of genius
for Shakespeare to realize
the metaphoric implications
of this, he did, but the
metaphor is embedded in the way
ordinary people named
that flower for hundreds
and perhaps thousands of years.
Shakespeare is
collaborating there
with the wisdom of his culture,
with the shared understanding
of his society, in order to make
that brilliant line of poetry.
So we can take that idea that,
the notion of golden lads,
as a kind of emblem for the
collaborative energies that
are sometimes released
when artists collaborate
with the traditions
of their culture,
with the traditions of
naming, with the traditions
of understanding,
that are embedded--
and so therefore the
collaboration is a deep one.
It's an intellectual,
and an expressive,
and a creative collaboration
between the societies
understanding of things,
the cultures understanding
of things, and the artists
interaction with those.
And that's an aspect of,
an even deeper aspect
of what I mean when I say,
that consensus narrative,
and that movies are a
collaborative art form.
I've also tried to suggest,
again and again in the course,
that there are films and
many of, most of the films
we've seen in the semester, also
deserve the designation art.
And I don't want,
I've not really
wanted to turn the term art
into a kind of elitist category
from which we must
sort of retreat in awe,
and sort of before it.
I want us to think
of art in a simpler
and, I think more
useful way, as a form
of intelligence and competence.
In other words, when things
are done well in a work of art,
when a movie as well made,
when a poem is well made,
we admire it and we
respect it, and we
don't have to get mystical
about the qualities of art
in order to recognize that
intelligence and competence are
qualities that we value in
other aspects of experience,
as well as an art itself.
What do I mean specifically
by intelligence incompetence?
The most profound way of
understanding this argument
has to do with what I've
spoken about a number of times
in the course, I've sometimes
used the phrase organic form
to explain what I
meant in this regard.
But essentially the idea
has to do with the sense,
with a recognition that
a serious artist will
use instruments that further
his or her intentions
effectively and fully.
That is to say, that
there's a connection
between the formal or stylistic
choices that an artist makes,
and the content that is
part of the art work.
That is to say that there's
a link or a connection
between the formal choices
that a writer or a filmmaker
makes and the content
intended to be communicated.
And we can think of
the term competence
as having to do simply with
the idea of technical mastery.
In other words, a competent
poet is a master of language,
is a master of metaphor,
is a master of grammar.
You can't be a great poet
if you have no understanding
of grammar whatever, because
you be you'd be throwing away
one of the great
technical resources
of the language, which is
the complexity that grows out
of a mastery of grammar.
By the same token, you couldn't
have a serious filmmaker
who didn't have a deep
profound sense of what
it meant to create
a visual story, what
it meant to try to embody
meaning in audio, visual ways.
You couldn't have
a great filmmaker
who is oblivious entirely
to the visual nature
of his experience.
The filmmaker would--
any serious filmmaker
has to be always aware
of the special qualities
and properties of the medium
in which he or she is working.
So if we think or art then,
not as a mystical category,
but as an expression of
intelligence and mastery,
intelligence and
competence, perhaps we've
demystified it a
bit, and given us
grounds for actually
making judgments
about particular films,
and particular passages,
and moments in film.
And let me remind you
again, that a second version
of this argument about
the relationship, at least
in part about the
relationship between art
and what I had sometimes
called entertainment,
the greater complexity
or richness of art,
can be embodied also, not
only in this first principle
of a connection between the
stylistic and formal choices
and the content.
But in this second way,
in the second category
or second perspective as
well, in terms of what
I've called texture
or multiplicity.
The multiplicity principles.
Let me just quickly remind
you of a couple of examples
we've looked at in the course,
just as a way of giving you
some instances from
which you can--
from which you can
extrapolate your own responses
to other texts.
Do you remember for
example the scene
of that, that we looked
at fairly closely,
in McCabe and Mrs. Miller, that
disturbing ironic shoot out
on the bridge?
In which had me murderous young
killer goads a young former
into taking the gun
out of his holster,
and shoots him down
in cold blood, right?
Let me simply remind you
about the way in which,
part of what gave
that scene it's power
had to do with the
fact that there
was a psychological
dimension to it.
The young murderer who
was committing the murder
had been frustrated because
he tried to show off earlier
and not succeeded.
And that imparted a terrible,
horrible irony to the scene,
because you realize
that this murder is
completely fortuitous,
it's completely accidental.
If that little murderer
had succeeded earlier
in shooting the bottle
that was floating around
on the frozen pond, he probably
would not have challenged,
he definitely would not have
challenged this young farmer
to try to get back
his mojo and show
the people around him that
he knew how to handle a gun.
So what made this--
and of course, and then
that already created a kind
of complexity and texture.
But then, when we
add in the fact
that this scene itself is one
of the central iconic scenes
in all Westerns, two males
facing off against each other,
ready to shoot we,
come to realize
that the various anti-heroic and
ironic ways in which this shoot
out is handled,
throws a profoundly
critical and disturbing light
on dozens, and perhaps hundreds
of earlier such scenes that
have occurred in Westerns.
That the very basis of the
Western's embrace of violence,
it's notion that you
could achieve regeneration
through violence, is put
in question by that scene.
So there's a texture or
multiplicity the scene.
It forwards the story,
it shows a violent act,
it tells us something about
the psychology of the murderer,
but even more than
that, it resonates
through the whole
history of the Western,
because the shoot
out itself has been
shown in such an anti-heroic,
such an ironic light.
Texture, multiplicity.
Remember the moment
in Cabaret where
the Joel Gray character, the
interlocutor, at one point
kneels down while he's talking
during the mud wrestling scene,
picks up a piece of
mud on his finger,
rubs it on his face like
this, and gives himself
with Hitler mustache.
I mean it's a rich
comic moment, but is
more than that, especially
in the context of,
as the film proceeds.
We understand from that
moment that the Nazis
are objects of fun and mockery.
Not that dangerous,
it would seem,
at least at that the cabaret
feels superior to it.
And of course, when we think
about the course of the film,
when we think about how the
Nazis moved from the periphery
to the center of
the movie, we come
to recognize that that moment,
especially in retrospect,
that moment has
a particular kind
of ironic original
richness, that's partly
a function of the
obliviousness that everyone
in the cabaret, and even
the Joel Gray character,
despite his apparent
cynicism and worldliness
seems to have about--
they're innocent,
they're naive about
the power and danger
of the rise of the Nazis.
And let me give you one last
example, although there are
many others that we mentioned.
Do you remember the
moment in the passage
I showed you from the De
Sica movie, Umberto D?
That very brief moment where we
see a man get on a tram, a bus,
and sit next to someone on
the bus, and the bus moves.
It's a completely
wordless sequence,
and there's a character
we've never seen in the film
before who sits down
next to the protagonist,
no words exchanged.
When our protagonist gets
up and gets off the bus,
the camera lingers briefly
on the man he left behind,
and we see that
man go like this.
And what I suggested
to you, again,
I suggested that
this was a moment
of richness and complexity,
of multiplicity in a way.
Because one implication
of that scene
is that the man, this stranger
that we'll never meet again,
that we only saw for
one brief instant
in the course of the film,
might have concealed the story
as deep as rich and as
moving as that of our hero
Umberto D., who is
now leaving the tram,
and we will shortly
be following him.
Again, a moment of
complexity or richness
that embodies central
meanings, helps
us to see central
meanings in the text.
Well I have a final
example of this kind
of texture or multiplicity.
It's an example I
had hoped to show you
what we talked about
Kurosawa last week,
but I didn't quite make
enough time in my lecture,
and I want to show it here,
as a kind of final homage
to that great director, and
as a way of reminding you
of the variety of performances
that the great actor Toshiro
Mifune, who plays the rapist
in Rashomon, was capable of.
So here is a scene, a very minor
scene, actually, from the film,
from the Kurosawa
film, Seven Samurai,
which I mentioned last time.
Let me set the context for
you, before I show it to you.
It's a very brief scene.
Seven Samurai, which I've
sometimes shown in this course,
I actually toyed with
the idea of having
to watch both Rashomon
and Seven Samurai,
but Seven Samurai is
a very long movie,
and I sometimes warn
students about it
when I show it in the class.
I decided not to
do it, but I hope
all of you over your
Christmas break,
soon, will look
at Seven Samurai.
It will resonate,
especially for you,
since you've just seen
an earlier Kurosawa film.
Well, this immensely long film
has a wonderful epic amplitude.
And the long first
section of the film
involves, essentially,
the assembling
of a group of
samurai who are going
to go to a village to defend
this village of farmers
from the deprivation of bandits.
When the film
opens, some farmers
aren't make their way to a great
city, trying to find samurai
who will come and defend them.
And the first
section of the film
shows this group of samurai
slowly coming together,
but only six of them are
in the group, because there
was a seventh who
tried to join them,
the Toshiro Mifune
character, but he
was rejected in the
earlier part of the film
that we haven't yet seen.
That we have seen, but
when you look at the clip,
you will not seen yet, because
he's not really a samurai,
he's is a commoner
who was trying
to fake that he was a samurai.
He grew up top knot,
he can handle a sword,
but they could tell
in various ways,
he didn't know the
poetry that samurai
knew, a lot of ways in
which they figured out
that the Mifune character
really was not a samurai.
So they didn't let
them join them.
And in this scene
we're going to see,
it's two or two and
a half minutes long,
and this is one
reason I wanted you
to look at it,
because it's so brief,
and its basic
function is so simple.
The point of the scene is to
get the samurai to the village
where the central aspect,
where the central adventure
of the film will take place.
So we could almost think of
part one as a kind of prologue,
or at least an
introductory preparation,
and the film really isn't
going to get going in one sense
until after this
transition moment.
So the sequence we're looking
at has a very simple narrative
function, it's to
get the samurai
from the city to
the rural village,
and we see them
making this trip.
But as you'll see, the scene
has a much greater multiplicity,
a much greater significance than
simply this simple narrative
significance of moving the
actors to a new location.
Here we go.
And see he's following
them in the back there
and they say go away.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHTER]
[WHOOPING]
[WHOOP]
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[WHOOPING]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Alright, so a
scene of unexpected comedy,
but what else?
Can you see how much
is going on there?
If we think about the scene
for a moment, we can see,
OK, the first
function of the scene
is to get them to the village.
But it's a wonderful example
of the multiplicity principle,
it seems to me.
It forwards the story
in some simple sense,
but what does it also do?
It defines the samurai
in some basic way.
First of all, the legitimate
samurai have a sense of humor.
But even more than
that, as we're
watching this scene, what do
we see, among other things?
A wonderful very brief
dramatization of the conflict
between man and nature.
Think of a raw those
natural environments
are in that sequence.
And the extent to which
we also-- the film
itself is in many ways--
a sub-theme in the film
is the relationship
between human beings
and natural forces,
this scene implicitly
sets that them up without
doing anything fancy
or calling our attention to it.
What else does it do?
It defines the Mifune character
really richly and fully.
He's something of
a clown, isn't he?
He likes attention, there's
something deeply theatrical
about him.
See the way he, he knew the
other samurai were watching him
when he caught the-- What
else did we learn about him?
He's also unbelievably
competent.
He jumps in that freezing
water and he catches
a fish with his bare hands.
And one implication
of this scene
may very well be that one the
things to the Mifune character
is trying to do is show the
samurai how competent is.
And you see, he ends up
leading them to the village.
And of course, you might
guess, do you think he remains
excluded?
No of course not,
he ends up joining.
He is the seventh samurai,
and becomes the seventh
as the film goes on.
So we, Mifune's nature is
defined for us in action
more than in words, we have
the theme of nature versus man,
we have the broader definition
of the nature of the samurai
group itself, and we get
an action that also moves
the story to a new location.
And one reason that I find this
example such a powerful one,
is that many people watching
this movie never even
remember this scene, because
it's hardly-- even though it is
very dramatic scene, isn't it?
The fact is there's so many
astonishing, dramatic, visually
memorable scenes in the
film, that most viewers who
don't have the advantage of
having this scene singled out
for them would never
even remember it.
And that's exactly
why it's so valuable,
it seems to me, because if it
plays a relatively minor role
in the film.
Its role in the film is
fairly simple and structural,
but even in that simple two
and a half minute sequence,
a great deal is going on.
It's a wonderful
instance, it seems
to me, of what we mean by
texture or multiplicity.
If you are aware of
this principle when
you look at other forms
of art, not just films,
I think you'll find
your sense of what
is going on in a
particular text,
or a particular expressive form,
will be immensely enlarged.
And I hope you apply these
ideas not just to movies
in the future, but to
other but to other forms
of expressive
experience as well.
I also, at the end
of this course,
as at the end of
every semester, am
afflicted by a
sense of gratitude
that I can't always fully
express to my students.
I've been doing this
for a long time,
I was thinking as the class
opened this afternoon looking
out at your faces,
I realized that one
of the most amazing things
about being a professor
is that your basic clients stay
young, and they keep you young,
they keep you young, even
though they also, in some ways
make you more and more
conscious of the gap between you
and your students
in some respects.
I have no doubt
that part of what
has made my career
a satisfying one,
and certainly what has made
me a much, much better teacher
than I might
otherwise have been,
has been the enthusiasm
and welcoming interest
that I've felt from virtually
every student I've ever taught.
And that's especially
true in this course,
and it's been especially
true in the semester.
So I want to end then,
by saying thank you.
In a way, symbolically,
I'd like to say thank you
to the students
I've been teaching
for more than 35 years at MIT,
for whom you are stand ins.
But most of all, I
want to thank you.
You make me, teaching
makes me, feel serious.
Being able to introduce students
to these astonishing works
of art has always seemed to me
to be a privilege for which I
was unable to express,
fully, my gratitude .
So thank you very much.
Have a wonderful life.
[BLANK AUDIO]